what's up mkbhd here so
can you game
in 8k
and would you even really want to that's
the question that i'm going to try to
answer with this video which you guys
know what that means uh this video is
gonna be 8k what the whole thing yeah
the whole thing it's going to be rough
on the processing but hey we're doing it
with all the hype about these consoles
though with the ps5 coming out with the
xbox series x and i've done videos about
both of them this sort of conversation
started to drum up again where
did the pc games really do that much
more than console games can these new
consoles
essentially be
pc gaming and you wouldn't be crazy to
think that by the way a lot of what
we've seen with new consoles as people
try to decide which one to upgrade to
have shown a lot a pretty big
generational leap
and so we're impressed with that but
that's when the pc gaming community gets
in my ear and they're like hey marquez
look that's cool and everything but the
real power still comes from the real
computer so of course this wouldn't be
an mkbhd video on 8k gaming without a
little bit of an exclusive so
this is the first time anyone's seeing
on camera the new nvidia geforce rtx
3090 so this is the highest end in
nvidia's new 3000 series it's a gigantic
huge graphics card uh but this is the
top of their new lineup and this is
capable of things that no new console
will even really be able to touch of
course we're talking about 8k gaming now
of course frame rate is king and i've
said that myself i said that in xbox
video but if you want to maximize
detail and immersion in every possible
way in this gaming world you also need
high resolution and so that's why we're
trying to answer the question can you
even game right now in 8k and if
anything can do it this can now you may
remember an older video where i did try
to game in 8k that was three years ago
believe it or not and looking back it
was worth a shot we had the dell 8k
monitor we had a powerful computer but
there were a lot of workarounds
happening for one you needed two cables
from the computer to the monitor and it
was stitching the whole thing together
and when we finally got it running i
mean it ran at 8k technically but you
saw the footage it wasn't amazing but
now it's 20 20. so we've got to step our
game up like mr beast would want us to
so remember this this is the 88 inch 8k
oled tv from that dope tech video it's
back
and main gear has also stepped up their
game so this is their f-131 so this is
their custom computer basically built
around the 3090 so if the 3090 is as
nvidia says built for 8k gaming then the
rest of this computer's got to be built
for 8k gaming too and it is so intel
core i9 10 900k so that's 10 cores 3.7
gigahertz space clock turboing up to 5.3
gigahertz you got 32 gigs of fast hyperx
fury ram in here an msi mpg z490 gaming
motherboard they're always great with
names and then a terabyte samsung nvme
ssd the 970 pro is the boot drive and
then there's another two terabyte ssd
for mass storage you know for stuff you
don't need to access quite as quickly so
it's all in a custom built aluminum
chassis you see the rgb in there you see
that mkbhd logo the matte black outside
the tinted glass and the side panel this
thing means business well not not
business i mean unless unless 8k gaming
is your business then
that's a pretty sweet business anyway
let's get into it also don't worry this
isn't a review of the new card there are
no benchmarks in this video this is just
about 8k gaming but i'm sure we'll have
all of that and more very soon when the
linus tech tips video and the hardware
connects videos drop matter of fact i'll
link both of those below when they do
actually drop their videos about the
card because i'm sure people are
interested in that but also i think it's
pretty safe to say this card will
probably crush synthetic benchmarks
all right so we got a little setup going
here the main gear computer on the desk
next to me and the 8k tv in front of me
i want to show you guys something really
quick though so on this built for 8k
graphics card it's got hdmi 2.1 ports
like i talked about and that's what
enables that single cable to do 8k out
and this is the hdmi cable we're using
and uh if you look at it it's a little
thicker it's a little more
averse to like bending uh but this is
the type of cable you'll need to get 8k
through a single cable
to the tv and now if i go ahead on the
desktop and check out display settings
you can see there you go 7680 by 4320
is the resolution we're getting so
we're ready to play all right so we got
a few games installed and i want to play
first one i want to show is forza
horizon 4. i've been a driving game type
of person for a long time sports games
and driving games but i'm pretty sure
seeing all the detail of the map and the
car in a driving game is gonna be a
major advantage to having this many
pixels
and there's this pretty sweet demo mode
that we'll go through that has like four
different seasons and a bunch of
different cars and
it's a pretty sweet demo okay so now
we're in the game
and i have the controller actually
connected
this
intro though
i think when they make these they don't
render these at 8k so this is less than
8k i think this is either
4k or maybe 1080p it doesn't look as
good
as 8k gaming but
let's go into video
oh there it is right off the bat
8k
60fps
all right
here's what i see oh the center
festival
and even this
i think
i don't think we're 8k yet but it looks
so good ever you want to be
that doesn't look okay
all right we're almost there
about to drive a sena directly into a
giant screen
let me show you this is definitely
what's happening
[Music]
horizon is here to stay
all right
so right off the bat it's telling me
we are like locked at 60 fps
so in the autumn setting i'm seeing like
all these leaves on the ground
all the leaves on the trees
all the detail in the sky
it's stuff you would still see at
1440p or 1080 but it's that much crisper
and i'm driving
a little bit recklessly while trying to
talk at the same time
oh god a cena would not make it through
that all right let's see what
inside the car oh i cracked the
windshield already beautiful
wow that is the mclaren steering wheel
for sure it's not exactly what my hands
would look like but
that's that's pretty good okay now you
get to winter i've done this before the
winter is insane you see every little
snowflake falling on the screen
everything
no matter what perspective you're in
you're getting snowflakes
oh wow
okay
still pretty much locked at 60 fps if we
wanted to go higher we'd need a higher
pressure rate screen
there's these little smoke things that
come up
and the smoke i don't know if it looks
as realistic but like
once you start to game at 8k you start
to notice like every single little thing
the developer decided to put in the game
it's like when you watch a high
resolution animated movie and you know
that everything in the movie
had to be intentional because it had to
be animated in
it's kind of the same thing with this
game like everything you see on this map
and
everything you hit with the car and
everything that falls out of the sky
it's all very intentional to give you a
more immersive feeling
and you notice
all of it
like all these fences i'm hitting in
this dirt and splashing all right let's
see if i can actually get some
some good times in in this demo while
the lasers fire into the sky distracting
me
all right cutscene
i feel like you can kind of see it
shift down to 1440 or 1080 in the
cutscenes and then back up to 8k when
the gaming starts again because it's
pre-rendered stuff here
all right
yeah that's not 8k wow
there is a k
it's very clear when it turns back on
all right guys this will be easy just
don't miss a checkpoint
this bikes with the smoke and now it's
just a lot of leaks
lots of textures
the fans in the back of the car
let me get in the car for a second
so sick
all the water droplets on the screen too
each of them has a reflection in it of
the world behind it like as if you were
actually looking through a camera back
here
all the water droplets on the top of the
car
hey blue
needle i'm loving this i would be if i
had this set up at home i would never
stop playing this at 8k has the gpu
struggled yet okay now we're down to 50
fps right 96
but like when there's that much stuff
happening on the screen at once
i'm kind of not shocked you're pushing a
lot of pixels 30 plus megapixels for
every single frame
a lot of wind
looks like i'm the only one left
god that's good oh that transition
though
and then this is the last part of the
cutscene it's summer
we're back in the center i'm pretty sure
again this pre-rendered part not quite
and then it switches to 8k wow
oh we're flying
oh we are flying
we gotta catch the centenario
and the bugatti up there
while the jets and the leaves and
everything distract me
holy moly i like how the speedo is in
kilometers per hour but my
my actual attack is an mph
catch the bug catch the bug that was way
too easy i shouldn't have caught the bug
that easily
oh boy i can tell you as i'm distracted
by the interior of this car from being
in high-end mclarens that's exactly what
the menu looks like when you're driving
the car
you do not want to miss out on watching
this
get around
i mean the car
i can't breathe
that's fun
i'm telling you you can tell when it
switches from the pre-rendered like i'm
going to say 1440p looking cutscenes
which look amazing
right into the actively rendering
gameplay i swear you can see it switch
and it looks really good when you
actually get into it alright let's try
another game alright this next game is
called control ultimate edition i'm
already in the game right now and it's
showing in 8k 52 fps so i'm just looking
around here
and
this animation of hitting books i think
is hilarious
but also i want to show you something
real quick so if i go into video
settings options
and switch
render resolution so this is other
things in the environment that it's
rendering out to 5k
you can see if we resume the game now
now it's actually
starting to work the gpu i'm down to 21
fps
the clearly what it's rendering back
there is super high resolution so if i'm
trying to see every single detail you're
going to be losing frames
21 fps now but when i have the actual
resolution of the game set to 8k which
it is
and then render resolution of the world
set to 2k
maybe even let's go 4k and see how it
does
resume game
36 fps
so i think really if we're going to have
the best experience
that's going to have to stay at
2k so
it's not invincible the card itself
isn't going to literally do anything you
ask at it so you can see now
the world is a little lower resolution
but i mean clearly the character is
still high quality and the game is so
high quality
let's go out this door this has been a
creepy game oh
oh oh
what is this
floating
what
bro i
okay okay
okay this is where it's gonna really
show that i'm not actually a good gamer
oh god
how long till i die
do the thing oh okay well
exposed i think you can tell this is
this is the type of game that would
benefit from i think a little bit higher
refresh rate like the the driving game
obviously higher refresh rate but gaming
is like full immersion you need the
detail also
um this is the type of game where
if you're really just trying to get
immersed and truly horrified by a horror
game like look at these look at these
textures
look at these textures all these are so
high quality the reflections
the character herself and i when i when
i go up to like a piece of glass and you
can see her reflection in the glass too
like that's the type of stuff your eye
expects to see
when you're actually
somewhere where there would be a
reflection so
this is pretty sweet all right i have
learned a lot i think i'm ready to give
a conclusion to answer the question in
the title of the video
can you game in 8k
yes
especially if you have a 30 90 you can
handle pretty much any game in pretty
much any resolution now the world of
gaming in 8k is not just a great gpu and
a great game you also need an 8k display
and that world of 8k gaming monitors
doesn't really exist yet so that that
little piece of the puzzle that's less
to plug in
is still not very mature yet we had that
dell ak monitor years ago we have this
lg 8k tv that's thousands of dollars you
probably still don't have a need to try
to game an 8k yet in 2020. but if you do
actually have the right setup gaming can
be spectacular at a higher fresh rate or
high resolution if you have the right
setup and this is more than enough to be
the right setup i'm just i just want to
get like a comparison now between the
best that the consoles have to offer
because i've been
somewhat of a console gamer for the past
couple years you see me play 2k all the
time you see me play need for speed all
the time things like that
i'm just trying to figure out how big is
the difference between those games on
say a 4k tv
versus the 8k stuff that this is kicking
out
so far
really good stuff and yes if you're a pc
master race person you will be able to
say the consoles can't do this
officially kicking out 60 fps at 8k
it's glorious it's beautiful so that's
been my experience
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace